[Music]
what's up gq my name is ron i also go by
ron dez i'm a barber and a colorist at
h2 salon today's look is inspired by
russell westbrook we're going with a
copper fade let's meet our client ronnie
hey what's up man it's going brother
nice to meet you like what
i'm excited all right let's have some
fun today
let's talk about russell's hair
evolution he's been playing with
different looks playing basketball
in 2013 2014 he's still kind of playing
it safe he added a little more texture
to his hair 2015 now we're getting spicy
now he's got a more of a fade darker top
texture 2016 faux hawk it's a good
switch up he's coming out of his comfort
zone a little bit 2019 he braided it up
with the fade on the sides clean look
nice edge up 20 21 he cut it down back
to a caesar wow this is the look we're
going for right here the copper look i
like fade on the sides with the dye and
every dye and everything
i won't say it's simple but it's more of
a casual look it's not jumping out too
far you can still look professional in
whatever you're doing i like it let's do
it
since i've never dyed my hair before is
there anything i should worry about
honestly the only thing i would say is
your maintenance of your hair don't
shampoo as much wash out your hair with
conditioner as much as you can and
probably shampoo once a week so let's
get started right all right all right
[Music]
step one we're gonna mix the color step
two we're gonna apply the color step
three as we're applying it we're gonna
wrap his head have him sit for 30
minutes wash and condition his hair
after after that we're going to get
straight into the actual haircut the
reason i want to start with the color
first i kind of want to start with a
fresh canvas before i go into the cut so
first we're going to drape you
[Music]
let's get started with mixing the color
we're going to use girol we're going to
use 6rr
and then we're going to use 30 volume as
the base i'm going to put my gloves on
first
mixing the color right now we also had
like a nice golden copper color with
your texture it's going to translate
well nice i'm excited yeah
when i'm doing color i like to start off
with the sides and then come back into
the crown
i definitely feel a little bit of
tingling yeah so that's pretty normal
after i cover the surface i go into the
scalp itself and start applying like a
little bit you want to get to the root
of the hair
now i'm starting to go into the actual
top of the hair
i really thought you know this was going
to be a bit more horrifying but so far
so good
i'm just making sure the application
doesn't actually get on his skin
i use a shower cap because it's
transparent i can actually see the color
change if i need to let it sit longer
we're going to put the timer for 30
minutes and then rinse the hair out
shampoo and then condition
all right guys we just finished rinsing
the application out we followed up with
a conditioner to apply more moisture to
his hair so his hair isn't as dry after
risking out the conditioner now we're
ready to dry his hair
so now i'm going to blow dry his hair
i'm going to add a leave-in conditioner
to protect the scalp from the heat from
the blow dryer itself
why uh why such a small amount
you don't need that much because you
don't want to overload it on your scalp
kind of want it to just to sit not to
really saturate the scalp
[Music]
as you can see the color came out really
good and gold look kind of brown copper
look we're gonna have fun now get to the
cutting part
russell's look is a short fade with a
copper die tone i want to start off low
i never started so high because i want
to give myself room to work we're going
to take the top down to a you want to go
with a four or three
we can go to three three i know that
we're mimicking russell's look but i
want to get the client his own identity
with this cut we might spice it up jazz
it up a little more here we go we're
going to start with the fade so i'm
going to set my guideline with a liner
i'm basically going to give them a drop
fade so you see that transition from the
grain of the color to the skin
[Music]
these are my soft liners the andes
clippers just to get around the nape
area and behind the ears
[Music]
so now that we started with the setup
line i'm gonna take his hair down to a
three
yeah you think you switch from a three
to a two yeah no problem so with that
being said i'm going to be using my
andes clippers to knock down the hair
tool too
[Music]
so we're trimming down the hair to a two
then i'm gonna finish up with the fade
after
[Music]
so the next part of this haircut i'm
gonna actually lay his hair down with a
one and a half just to smooth it out
this is chopping down like the loose
ends anything that's sticking up
our next step we're gonna begin to fade
so i'm gonna go to my andes masters
i'm gonna start another guideline where
i can work my one into a half and back
to a zero back to a ball fade and then
i'm going to come back up and finish off
with a two going down to a one and a
half to a 1a
[Music]
so as you can see it's on one side of
the hair to transition from light to
dark
and voila there we have it the fade is
done so now we're going to line you up
and we're going to clean up your beard
make me look clean and neat
[Music]
i'm going to apply a little bit of hair
enhancement on his sides
so now i'm going to begin to line his
front line and give him that symmetrical
look that he desires i'm just bringing
back his line a little bit so he has a
more form line i'm using baby-less
trimmers
[Music]
[Applause]
russell westbrook's look he has more of
a mustache and a little soul patch you
kind of want to keep that look or you
want to keep your beard give me the
russell westbrook look so you won't go
all the way go all the way
so what we're going to do here with his
face we're going to line up his goatee
and his mustache just like russell
whisperer the key with the mustache
honestly for me is not to make it too
skinny it kind of has to have some type
of dimension
[Music]
final part of this haircut i'm actually
going to raise your line and raise it a
mustache just to clean it up and then
we're good to go
[Music]
all right ron you ready
i'm ready i'm excited
[Music]
oh
i like it i like it it's smooth
[Music]
lineup is pretty sharp i love it russell
westbrook maybe next time we can try
something different like the blue with
the stars on the side let's do it
thank you always
i love it man i'm gonna show it can't
wait to show my friends
thank you once again always bro all
right yeah
so that was russell's copper fade thank
you so much gq for having me until next
time